battle to reopen schools all across the
country's back but one member of the
mainstream media has already decided
who's to blame if kids aren't back in
the class this fall
i want to put a pin in the idea that
republicans will blame the biden
administration for kids not being in
school if kids aren't in school it's
because republicans didn't get
vaccinated and republican governors
stood in the way of mass mandates that
would make it possible
this comes the chicago teachers union
have said that the delta variant could
derail their plan to return to in-person
learning
this fall and it's worth pointing out
that in chicago the teachers there are
going door-to-door
in communities where they have low
vaccination rates and they're urging
families to get vaccinated so they can
make sure
that the schools are safe as possible
but shannon what's your take on this how
do we get back to in-person learning
in a world where the delta variant is
spreading and it's having an impact on
children
well i think anytime you start blaming
people for contracting a respiratory
illness um there's a lot of shaming that
goes with that and out in san francisco
they've got a super high vaccination
rate but they're also having a surging
rate of cases those aren't republicans i
mean
this is something that is going to get
to people um for various reasons
including vaccinated people as well
but my confusion is somewhat with the
teachers unions too because they
demanded to be at the front of the line
for the vaccinations which we all
thought
that's a good idea we got to get them
back in there with kids along with first
responders and healthcare workers they
should be near the front
and now we've got the major teachers
unions coming out saying you cannot
mandate that our teachers have to get
vaccinated in order to go back so
there's a there are plenty of people if
you're looking to assign
the reasons why we may not get back to
the classroom
greg i want to put a pin in the idea
i want to put a pin in the idea that's
my impression of nicole wallace i'm
beginning to think
her show is a cry for help every culprit
in every segment is a republican the
party that she belonged to it's like
she's an
angry teenager getting back at her
parents by dating a drug dealer
in this case it's you know being the
town mascot for left-wing masters at
msnbc
but i i'm gonna go back to what i've
been saying forever and i know this is
gonna happen in my lifetime this is a
great opportunity
to redefine and remake education the
teachers union have made it clear it's
not about the kids
it's about them every every every
republican running for office has to
make
uh school choice their number one
principle because if you solve that
if you solve education you're gonna
solve crime and racism because it's all
bubbling out of that same
mess that in which we stupidly hand it
over to unions
this is the most important thing in our
country is education for children and i
don't even like children and i'm aware
of this
but we have allowed this to decay and
we're letting these
lunatics control this it is time again
to create the peloton model
which is me which is merry charismatic
charismatic
highly paid teachers nationalize it so
they can teach at home if you're going
to be at home
doing these zoom classes why not get the
very best instructors in the world
and make them stars why why does it have
to be local
nationalize it get rid of this crap well
and
one thing i will say is interesting the
florida board of education today was
having a meeting talking about the
masking mandates because governor
desantis is you know
you know his policies down there they
actually were told that students can
move and the money can move with them if
students
if parents want to take kids out of
schools that the money can follow with
the kids and that for a number of
different
different issues could be a huge you
know
sean d'angelo is that his name the guy
that's behind this move is like it's
it's spreading
it's an amazing thing well i mean dean i
mean that that is a point right but
there's also this idea that we what
we're
what we're seeing take place in in the
state of tennessee for example the
director of health there talked about
the fact that
she's afraid that by next week in her
state there will be no more icu beds in
their children's hospitals because of
the spread of the delta variant
and her response is one of the best ways
to slow the spread as we go back to
school for children is
by ensuring that kids have mask on it's
a simple thing that they can do to stop
the spread
in a world where some of our children
can't get vaccinated if you're 12 and
under you can't get vaccinated
so this is a way for us to control the
spread so we don't have kids in icus
there is no evidence that um the delta
variant is more severe
period uh in europe they didn't mask
their kids under the age of 12 and they
had the same outcome they did not have a
worse result
than the united states i'll quote carol
markowitz the new york post
who for a year and a half has been
talking about the damage
being done to our children because of
these power hungry work averse
science deniers known as the teachers
unions that
literally hate our children horrific
irreparable damage
educationally developmentally
emotionally psychologically here's what
carol said
study after study disregarded study
showed that even unvaccinated children
are safer than many vaccinated adults
kids don't spread covet the same way
schools aren't infection hot spots
kids rarely get sick from covet and when
they do it's no worse
than a cold but instead these liberal
lowlifes in the white house
the education secretary and the like
they're
softening the beach for these teachers
unions to pull another con
job on america because they don't want
to get back to work
60 percent of teachers in new york city
not vaccinated so that's the problem
that the likes of
randy weingarten again trampling
children go back to school
that's a lie because they would have
been said that yesterday they would have
been in school
for a year and a half if that woman
let me add one more thing in terms of
that dull tool
over at msnbc she's quite the bigot
if she's blaming unvaccinated parents
for their children
not being in school what about the
two-thirds of unvaccinated
black individuals in new york city is
she blaming them for the reason their
children are suffering
something to think about jesse this is
like the republicans are the ones that
defunded the police line
exactly so easy to do oh let me try that
ready here's how it works
richard the democrats stormed the
capitol on january 6th
i mean come on it's absurd she can't get
away with that and we won't let her get
away with it
so here are the largest school districts
in the united states new york
chicago los angeles and miami-dade
which school district was open all last
year and which school district will be
open all
this year with no masks miami-dade
because
it's governed by a republican governor
and it has a republican mayor
all of these other districts are run by
democrats
so to say that in all these big
districts it's republican anti-vaxxers
that are spreading delta
these are largely minority majority
cities
with they vote three to one democrat
that's the truth
and she can't handle it richard she
can't handle i agree with you there what
i will say in all those districts with
you
in la and in new york what you have is
teachers who are saying that we need
more school nurses we need more
librarians we need social work we
already got 100 bill richard an
emotional designer
students and that's what they want
another 100 billion hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else